y
[Música]
joe biden se pronunció a favor de
cambiar las reglas del senado para que
avance en los proyectos de ley que
expandiría y protegería en el derecho al
voto en eeuu esto implicaría acabar con
el llamado filibuster una medida de
larga data que permite al partido
minoritario exigir que haya una mayoría
de 60 votos para aprobar una legislación
de acuerdo con el más reciente informe
del banco mundial la economía global
presentará una desaceleración tanto en
2022 y 2023 por su parte el foro
económico mundial dio a conocer su
informe de riesgos globales para los
próximos 10 años y entre ellos destaca
la crisis por el cambio climático y la
desigualdad
la ub se pronostica que más de la mitad
de la población europea contraerá o
micro en un lapso de 8 semanas
la variante sigue expandiéndose en el
continente y provocando un alza en el
número de contagios francia por ejemplo
registró un nuevo récord en la última
jornada con más de 368.000 casos
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en francés 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos en estados unidos
el presidente joe biden sentó una fuerte
posición en contra del bloqueo
legislativo por parte de la oposición
republicana durante un discurso en
atlanta el presidente se mostró a favor
de cambiar las reglas del senado para
que su partido pueda avanzar con
proyectos de ley con amplias reformas al
derecho al voto eso implicaría
deshacerse del llamado filibuster esto
en medio de las restricciones al derecho
al voto impulsadas en al menos 19
estados por los republicanos tras la
derrota de donald trump en 2020 baden
aseguró que la lucha por el alma de la
nación continúa
y hoy lo estoy dejando claro para
proteger nuestra democracia apoyo
cambiar las reglas del senado tanto que
tengan que ser cambiadas para evitar que
una minoría de senadores bloquee las
acciones sobre el derecho al voto y
desde washington nuestro corresponsal
cristóbal vázquez nos explica que es el
llamado afilió booster y las
implicaciones de un eventual cambio en
las reglas de la cámara alta- en un
emotivo discurso desde atlanta yo bailé
en reiteró que la democracia está en
peligro porque los republicanos y el
expresidente camps están tratando de
cambiar las leyes electorales a nivel
estatal para ganar las próximas
elecciones el ex presidente quiere
quitarles la opción de voto al que no lo
apoya afirmó biden en referencia a las
leyes estatales que impulsan los
republicanos y que limitan el voto por
correo y la votación de estudiantes y
minorías entre otras medidas al respecto
bardem afirmó que apoyará el cambio de
reglas y la eliminación del famoso
filibuster en el senado para proteger el
derecho al voto si es necesario
y que tratará de acabar con la medida
que le da potestad al partido que es
minoría en el senado en este caso el
republicano de requerir 60 votos sobre
100 para aprobar cualquier tipo de leyes
en este caso sería la aprobación de la
ley john lewis para prevenir la
discriminación en el voto dándole
también potestad al gobierno federal de
revisar las leyes electorales estatales
y también para aprobar la ley de
libertad de voto que asegura la
posibilidad de voto por correo y el voto
por adelantado lo complicado es que
aunque se logre acabar con el philip
astro y los demócratas puedan pasar
estas leyes con mayoría simple ni
siquiera es seguro que se pongan de
acuerdo los demócratas para lograr el
margen de 50 votos necesarios para
aprobar estas leyes electorales a nivel
federal
el banco mundial presentó un informe
donde pronostica que la economía mundial
registrará una ralentización pronunciada
en 2022 y 2023 esta reducción de sus
previsiones económicas son causadas
principalmente por el riesgo que supone
la aparición de nuevas variantes de kobe
19 como micrón veamos
la pandemia acabó con la débil
recuperación económica el banco mundial
rebajó su pronóstico de crecimiento
mundial a causa de los continuos brotes
de kobe 19 el organismo advirtió que la
demanda de los consumidores que había
crecido por los confinamientos se
disipará al igual que los apoyos
fiscales que varias economías sostenían
cuando llegó la pandemia
kovic sigue entre nosotros estamos
experimentando una ola de omicron los
niveles de deuda son bastante altos
tenemos presiones inflacionistas tenemos
retos relacionados con el clima cuando
esto se junta en un espacio político muy
limitado para las economías de los
mercados emergentes estos riesgos
aumentan la posibilidad de un aterrizaje
brusco
en el caso de américa latina el banco
mundial proyecta un crecimiento de
apenas el 2,6 por ciento en 2022 y 2,7
por ciento para 2023 mientras que el
crecimiento mundial también muestra una
clara desaceleración
de cara al futuro proyectamos una
pronunciada desaceleración y las cifras
son claras
[Música]
la economía mundial creció un 5 y medio
por ciento pero de cara a este año
veremos un crecimiento en torno al 4% y
el año siguiente la cifra baja al 3%
rosa pero no solo micro en amenaza de la
economía el foro económico mundial
publicó un informe donde destaca los
principales riesgos para la humanidad en
los próximos años entre los que figuran
la crisis climática la desigualdad que
se disparó con la pandemia en economías
emergentes la pérdida de empleos la
ciberseguridad la salud mental la deuda
pública y nuevas enfermedades
infecciosas
más del 50 por ciento de europeos
contraerá omicron en los próximos dos
meses y el ritmo de contagios se
mantiene según los datos de la
organización mundial de la salud europa
registró más de siete millones de nuevos
casos de coronavirus en la primera
semana de 2022 esto es más del doble que
el promedio de las dos semanas
anteriores la o&m se afirma que la
variante o micro ya está en la gran
mayoría de los países europeos y de asia
central el organismo agregó que la
escala de transmisión es tan alta que
están subiendo las hospitalizaciones
fifty off de cítricos y 50 de los 54
países de europa y asia central ya han
reportado casos de omicron y te comen
rápidamente se está convirtiendo en la
variante dominante en europa occidental
y ahora se está expandiendo a los
balcanes this rights the institute for
health metrics a este ritmo el instituto
de métrica y evaluación de la salud
prevé que más del 50 por ciento de la
población en la región se contagiará con
cómico no en las próximas seis a ocho
semanas en the next sixto weeks y
francia anunció un nuevo récord de
contagios diarios más
168 mil casos confirmados hace tan sólo
tres semanas el país superó por primera
vez en toda la pandemia los 100.000
positivos en un solo día y ahora los
contagios se han ido en aumento desde
que la variante omicron se ha convertido
en la dominante
seguimos en europa el primer ministro
británico boris johnson sigue bajo
escrutinio el parlamento citó a varios
de sus funcionarios por las fiestas en
downing street durante el confinamiento
luego de una nueva revelación que habla
de una reunión adicional a la que ya se
conocía johnson se rehusó a dar
explicaciones y envió a un secretario
luís muñoz tiene la historia
fiestas pandémicas llevan al límite al
gobierno británico la emisora itv reveló
una invitación de martín reynolds
secretario privado del primer ministro
boris johnson a una reunión de más de
100 personas cargadas de alcohol en
downing street- del 20 de mayo de 2020
el parlamento pidió la comparecencia de
johnson para que reconociera o negara su
asistencia pero el gobierno envió un
funcionario de bajo perfil
me disculpo no sin reservas por el
malestar que han causado estas
acusaciones el primer ministro ha pedido
que se lleve a cabo una investigación
ustedes
jesús la fiesta se celebró cuando el
país vivía fuertes restricciones con
escuelas cerradas y sin posibilidad de
despedirse de familiares víctimas de
kobe 19 el mismo día de la reunión el
secretario de cultura había hecho el
siguiente recordatorio terminado a
encontrar formas creativas y sin
multitudes de navegar por el coronavirus
es el mayor desafío para nuestros
escritores de recreación y ocio en este
momento se suena una alta funcionaria
del gobierno su grey con forma de mano
dura está investigando cinco fiestas en
departamentos gubernamentales
la policía ha pedido información para
iniciar una investigación
el partido laborista pide
responsabilidades es upson creo que su
ausencia lo dice todo igual que su
sonrisa ante los medios de comunicación
el público ya ha sacado sus propias
conclusiones puede huir pero no puede
esconderse lee kang
no es la primera crisis de boris johnson
por las fiestas en diciembre se conoció
que en las navidades de 2020 en downing
street también se saltaron las
restricciones detrás de las revelaciones
estaría dominique cummings antiguo
asesor que dejó el cargo por enfrentarse
con la actual esposa de boris johnson
y argentinas por estos días uno de los
lugares más calientes del mundo debido a
una ola de calor con temperaturas que
han superado los 40 grados centígrados
la situación ha incentivado una alta
demanda del servicio eléctrico lo que ha
generado el colapso del sistema y
apagones masivos de acuerdo con datos
gubernamentales más de 700 mil personas
sufrieron cortes de luz este martes en
la provincia de buenos aires- y su
capital las compañías encargadas han
informado que se ha restablecido el
suministro a la mayoría de los usuarios
pero unos 160 mil permanecían a oscuras
pasadas las 8 de la noche hora local
hasta que esta informativa en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]